-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
That's a crowd.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Well, guys, some good news
for President Biden --
over the past few months,
his approval rating
has gone up by five points,
to 42%.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Biden was like, "Thank God,
inflation finally got to me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Even Biden was surprised
by the results.
He triple-checked it,
like an at-home COVID test.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's like, "This can't be right.
This can't be right.
Honey, look at this.
Is this right?"
I'm not even sure
what caused the spike, really.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, apparently,
a lot of Americans thought --
[ Changes accent ]
Hey, I like how he
handled Easter.
[ Laughter ]
It's great news for Biden,
although it's hard to celebrate
when your approval
rating skyrockets
and it's still only 42%, but.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
former President Trump was
on the campaign trail
this weekend
and, in the Ohio Senate race,
he endorsed J.D. Vance,
who's running against a guy
named Josh Mandel.
I think Trump confused the names
J.D. Vance and Josh Mandel.
Watch this.
-You know,
we've endorsed Dr. Oz.
We've endorsed JP, right?
J.D. Mandel
[ Laughter ]
and he's doing great.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not even a person.
[ As Trump ]
Great guy.
JP Morgan is great.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You can't say enough
about JCPenney.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't think you can.
We love you, J.Lo.
We love you.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure if it's a ringing
endorsement when you're like,
"I fully support
what's-his-face.
[ Laughter ]
He's the best."
Trump said even the best leaders
make mistakes sometimes,
like our great president
AbraGeorge LincolnTon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did you guys see this?
Over the weekend,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
made a surprise visit to Ukraine
and met
with President Zelenskyy.
Here they are together.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see that photo again?
Looks like a mom
and her new trainer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering and whistling ]
Again --
I've said this before.
Why don't politicians
ever know what to do
with their arms in photos?
[ Laughter ]
It's just so bizarre.
Well, the White House
Correspondents Dinner
was on Saturday
and congrats to Trevor Noah
and President Biden.
They both spoke
[ Cheering and applause ]
and they did a great job.
Very funny, both of them, yep.
The dinner is a tradition
that goes back decades.
In fact, I saw a moment
from one of those early dinners
that kind of caught me
by surprise. Watch this.
-My childhood
in Abilene, Kansas,
wasn't easy.
I was so ugly,
my mother had morning sickness
after I was born.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I was so ugly,
my mother used to feed me
with a slingshot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, I drink too much.
The last time I gave
a urine sample,
it had an olive in it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
-That's interesting.
I didn't know that.
Have you seen those jokes?
-Wow.
-Yeah.
Oh, I read a new report
that said, last year, guys,
the FBI searched
over 3 million Americans'
electronic communications
without a warrant.
[ Oohs, ohs, and booing ]
People were like, "You can't
invade my privacy like that.
But wasn't Becky's text to me
like super weird?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it was --
There was a tone, right?
There was a tone?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, after reading
3 million texts and emails,
the FBI learned
that the only thing harder
than planning an attack
is planning brunch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I can't make it that weekend."
Some business news --
Spirit Airlines
has rejected JetBlue's offer
to buy them
and will merge
with Frontier Airlines, instead.
[ Oohs ]
-What?
-That's crazy. Picking Frontier
over JetBlue is like
deciding to fly Frontier
over JetBlue,
[ Laughter and applause ]
you know what I'm saying?
Imagine getting turned down
by Spirit Airlines?
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like getting
a rejection letter
from the University of Phoenix.
You go like, "Come on."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Get this --
I heard that inflation
is causing the cost of summer
camps to drastically increase.
Yeah, right now,
a lot of parents
are looking
at the high prices like,
"Camp iPad it is.
Here we go."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, this is cool --
over the weekend, at a track
meet in Philadelphia,
a 100-year-old man
ran the 100-meter dash.
-Whoo!
-It's exciting, although,
when he started the race,
he was 98.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sadly, he was disqualified
after testing positive
for every medication.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But what a moment.
After he finished,
his friends dumped a cooler
of Ensure over his head.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was a great moment
and congratulations to him.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]